are you personally yourself someone who
enjoys dancing are you I mean I don't
think I okay like I was watching him
there was you know late-night
commercials I watched those I can't
sleep anymore so I'm watching late-night
commercials and there's this one about
it's a guy selling DVDs if you still
people buying DVDs online on television
right and he's it's he says I can teach
you how to dance like NSYNC and boys to
men all those bands I can teach you
dance just like them because I taught
them I'm the one who taught them first
of all I was very disappointed because I
thought in sync and those guys that they
just did that I thought they just that's
why they're called NSYNC because they
have this amazing that the musical
starts and they just they just may have
all the same exact choices every time
they dance that's what I thought that
was your yeah your dream yeah about them
yeah and now I find out it's just this
guy taught him how to do it but then I'm
watching the commercial maybe this is
stupid you know you watch those things
this is stupid
but they're sure he's showing how he
took ordinary people and they're all
doing them by but they're doing it right
and he said you can have all these moves
if you watch the DVDs and I started
going I kind of want to get this DVD I
kind of want to get it and bring it home
and do like 30 minutes a night and then
I would just have all those moves and I
would never do them I would never dance
those moves
wait you'd learn them but then never do
them I have them they're mine they're
mine
uh-huh no one can make me feel like I'm
nothing yes
so it's secret it's your quiet secret
some guys looking at me like piece of
[ __ ] look at that fat piece of [ __ ]
and I'm like you don't know what I could
do right now
[Applause]
all right I think I like a ninja that
never draws his sword
you